[Music]
thank you
another question i had is can you please
explain the absent from the body is to
be present with the lord so that is
second corinthians 5 verse 8. and that's
that's uh
a lot of sunday people use that to say
when you die you go straight to heaven
the text is it the text is to be absent
with the body is to be present with the
lord it doesn't say when because at some
point after your absence for the body
yes you'll be present with the lord but
when it doesn't say when it doesn't say
immediately it does not say well and the
saint paul who said that he said in
first thessalonians 6 4 16 for the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel or
if the trump of god and the dead in
christ shall rise first paul cannot
contradict himself the same paul tells
us in first corinthians
15 verse 20 for since my man came death
by man came also the resurrection of the
dead
was as in adam all die even so in christ
shall all be made alive first
corinthians 15 20 and 21 22 and so paul
makes it clear in other places
that at death we go into the grave and
that's where we come from when jesus
christ come back so when he says in
the absence from the body is to be
present with the lord he doesn't mean
immediately he does not mean that
because other statements he makes makes
it clear he does not mean that absent
from the lord absent from the body means
you're dead yes one day yes you'll be
present with the lord but not right
after you die because not even jesus
right after he died went to the father
he was in the grave
and if jesus didn't go immediately why
could i why can i why should i vote
immediately or anybody else for that
matter
[Music]
you